a land information memorandum Lim report
is a summary of the relevant and most
important information that local council
holds on a property whether you're
buying or selling a property it's
essential that you're well-informed
about the legal and natural
characteristics of the building and land
your local council is required by law to
issue you a limb within ten days of
request we also offer a fast-track
option for those last-minute decisions
getting a limb report out to you sooner
if needed your limb will describe the
risk of natural hazards to the building
or land such as whether there has been
flooding or a slip if you're in a
tsunami zone and the nearest evacuation
routes the likely strength of shaking in
an earthquake or the degree of
liquefaction that's likely to occur in
the event of an earthquake your limb
will also alert you to hazards of the
land like whether or not it's
contaminated by hazardous substances or
contains
uncertified or uncompacted fill a limb
report will tell you if there are listed
significant natural cultural and
archaeological sites on the land these
might include protected areas of bush or
trees a heritage building or an old par
site alone we provide a record of all
consented building work this is helpful
in identifying potentially illegal and
unsafe building work that may cause
problems in the future
it will also give you information the
council holds on services such as the
location of water supply storm water and
sewage systems a limb can also warn you
if the building is on the leaky
buildings register or if the council is
aware of any bit amphetamine
contamination issues identifying these
issues early on may save you lots of
money and angst in the long term
Limor reports can offer lots of other
useful information such as the valuation
of the building and land payable rates
and rates owing and community services
such as the local rubbish day as a
potential buyer a Lim will help you
identify potential problems early on and
decide whether the property is worth
purchasing as a vendor streamline the
process with one less condition on sale
and say hey there's nothing to hide here
the knowledge you gain from a Lim report
means that you're minimizing your
exposure to risk buying with confidence
and ultimately giving yourself peace of
mind
[Music]